un accident se déroulait ce matin dans
la mine de charbon de liste viage naya
en sibérie chez à 3000 km à l'est de
moscou près de 300 personnes
travaillaient sous terre au moment du
drame un deuil de trois jours a été
décrété dans la région on retrouve notre
correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
bonjour verra expliquez-nous ce qui
s'est passé ce matin
bonjour se fie au moins onze morts et
des dizaines de disparus après un
accident dans une mine de charbon du
siège dans la région de kemerovo pour
l'instant les opérations de sauvetage
sont suspendus à cause du risque
d'explosion le président russe a dit mur
poutine a déjà exprimé ses condoléances
aux familles de victimes et sera tenu
informé de la situation sur la science
toute la journée je vous propose
d'écouter
aujourd'hui nous avons appris la
tragique nouvelle venant de kemerovo de
la mine de lysiane aia
le président a déjà reçu un rapport du
gouverneur sergueï tselikov
le président s'est également entretenu
par téléphone avec le ministre des
situations d'urgence alexandre
tchouprian qui sur l'ordre du président
avec le chef 2 aux roses techno d'or
alexandre très mills qui est maintenant
en route pour kemerovo afin d'organiser
la poursuite de l'opération de sauvetage
sur place
le président a donné les instructions
nécessaires au gouverneur aux autorités
de la région au ministre pour fournir
toute l'assistance nécessaire aux
victimes et faire le maximum d'efforts
pour poursuivre l'opération de sauvetage
le président poutine présente ses
sincères condoléances aux familles des
mineurs qui sont décédés c'est déjà
clair qu'ils sont morts et bien sûr nous
espérons qu'il sera possible de sauver
ceux qui se trouvent bloqués sous terre
ce prix qu après ce tour
l'alerté a été déclenchée ce matin à
8h30 l'aube heure locale après le
constat des donations importantes de la
plume et à une profondeur de 10 50 m sur
les 285 personnes présentes dans la mine
au moment de l'accident plus de 200 sont
dors et déjà hors de danger citant une
source anonyme parmi les services
d'urgences l agence de presse russe tass
a rapporté que l'incident avait été
causée par à l'information de poussière
de charbon entraînant la propagation des
fumées toxiques
le land depuis de 26 nations merci
beaucoup qu'elle verra goffman en direct
de moscou